wasn't there a story years ago where
Harvey Weinstein wanted to meet with you
like in a way this you kind of avoided
the home yeah you dodged that but well
here's one tell me how this all came
about this is wild because there was a
roast for Quentin Tarantino at the
Friars Club so that wasn't my first
roast with like Hollywood people I was
maybe 25 years old and I get the list of
everybody that's on the dais right well
Harvey Weinstein and Brett Ratner were
both there this was what ten years ago
and I remember I was like okay Harvey
Weinstein him Brett Ratner like these
are the two people that can make or
break your career in Hollywood like it
was just they were the scariest most
ominous like like powerful man and
you're 23 and thinking wow if I could
get to know these guys maybe they could
do mountain for I'm a kid I mean I just
was like that you know and I had written
all these jokes about them but at the
last minute I chickened out saying them
because I was too afraid like these guys
will ruin my career like that's what all
I heard was like these guys if you get
on their bad side like your career not
that I had a career to ruin what were
the jokes you were gonna I know you have
these were the Harvey Weinstein now this
was before any of this stuff came out
about him there were like rumors that
they slept with actors like I hadn't
heard that I'd heard that too you know
but it's the kind of thing where you
really cool this is true someone would
be doing something about it like it
didn't occur to anyone that this was
like untoward you know whatever but
anyway so I wrote all these jokes about
them I panicked a baby the jokes that
you never did about Harvey one okay Brad
oh yeah I never did this one Brett
Ratner
everyone in Hollywood says you have to
blow Brett Ratner to get into one of his
movies I blow Brett Ratner if would get
him to stop making people make fun of
Brett Ratner they say he's a bad
director that's not true right now
Barnes & Noble they actually have a
whole rack dedicated to Brett Ratner
movies it's called clearance that would
now be a Barnes and noble.com joke but
this was 10 years ago guys
Brett Ratner will not only take his
place next to great directors like
Quentin Tarantino and Martin Scorsese
he's also taken their ideas
techniques and style lots of Holly oh
this is [ __ ] crazy that I was writing
jokes about this but see lots of
Hollywood actresses have [ __ ] Brett
Ratner at least twice wants to get in
his movies and wants to get out that was
the narrative was like the actresses
used him to get in movies that's what
people would say right about - I get why
you were afraid to do these because
these guys seem kind of mean and
vindictive in a way that may be fine
yeah and like they could actually really
kind of keep you out of some stuff yeah
totally would you have about Harvey
Weinstein okay Quentin Tarantino's
movies are violent bloody and sometimes
leave a bad taste in your mouth which
also describes my last audition for
Harvey Weinstein but like did I because
you were aware on some of the rumors
about him less everyone had heard that
there was some weird [ __ ] with him but
no one quite knew what it was if it was
true we wouldn't be writing jokes about
like it wouldn't be funny if that so it
was like the fact that I wrote these
jokes are nuts like oh and then I just
went after his appearance Harvey
Weinstein what can I say about Harvey
that hasn't already been covered by a
lipitor commercial it's like you're fat
right that's good
rumor has it that Harvey Weinstein is a
total creep with women apparently the
only famous woman you haven't forced
yourself into a relationship with is
Jenny Craig I could listen to these odds
like a day I love them
Harvey Weinstein sleeps with so many
actresses Planned Parenthood took out ad
space on his taint that's good oh that's
pretty crazy Brett Ratner slept with so
many women he doesn't have the clap he
has the applause don't you wish you had
yes done those now that you look back on
it yes the fact that I was too scared I
mean that's a testament to how scary
these guys were I was too scared to do
jokes about that I know isn't that weird
we're all walking on eggshells it was
like you don't piss these guys off like
maintain the status quo Wow wild